[Music]
hello everyone my name is Juan Sebastian
Oviedo and I am a product manager in the
continuous integration continuous
delivery team in Google Cloud today I am
going to tell you about art affaire
registry the evolution of Google
container registry as the evolution of
Google container registry article
registry includes new features like
regional repositories multiple
repositories per project and repository
native identity access management
article registry gives you a scalable
build artifact management with security
and control you can focus on
differentiating your product offering
while enjoying the peace of mind of
knowing that your software delivery
process is backed by Google cloud
platform article registry is currently
in beta with docker support and alpha
support for Java and node.js artifacts
now my teammate ray will show you how
article registry integrates into the
Java development and release process
here we have a simple Java microservice
as you can see we have created different
artifact repositories in this GCP
project to manage the buter artifacts
for this application one for container
images in another for Java maven
artifacts these repositories are located
in specific GCP regions and they are
configured with a new repository native
identity access management provided by
artifact registry for example
permissions are configured to control
who can push or pull artifacts
the fact registry easily integrates with
your development and release to set if
you are building a common library in
Java to be used by all of your business
applications you can use maven or Grado
to build and publish the packages to
artifact registry when building your
container using docker or jib plugging
they can be configured to push container
images to artifact registry as well
now with all the artifacts stored in
artifact registry you can manage those
packages via the console in G command
line while applying consistent
permissions across your repositories
artifact registry integrates with Club
you'd in an third-party CI CD system
here we have set up a club you type line
that boosts the application publishes
the maven artifact to artifact registry
then builds and stores the container
image in artifact registry as well
from there we can easily deploy the
container into Google Cloud runtimes
such as kubernetes engine or cloud wrong
are they fight registry is the evolution
of container registry and gives you
scalable build on defect management with
security and control visit our
documentation to learn how to get
started with docker maven and NPM in
artifact registry
[Music]